so the republican party
wants to stop cancel culture
these are the same [ __ ] that
want to boycott
disney they want to boycott the nfl
because colin kaepernick is
is kneeling during the national anthem
burning their jerseys they want to
boycott harry potter you remember this
[ __ ]
and even the lorax
boycott the lorax dr seuss
and these people are bitching about
cancer culture in particular
mr jim jordan
i can see why this [ __ ]
definitely doesn't want cancel culture
as soon as the world is about to find
out how he hid
sexual allegations about his wrestling
team
i can see how this [ __ ] has a
vested interest on not being canceled
for [ __ ] that's controversial
and unity they're pro-unity and
anti-cancer culture
this is the same [ __ ] that have
been censoring
all the republicans who had who voted
for impeachment
and then the seven [ __ ] senators who
voted for conviction
their state parties are now canceling
them these are the people who are
anti-cancer culture and pro-unity
yeah because centering your senators
because they voted your conscience
boy that's all kinds of unity and [ __ ]
you [ __ ] really know how to get
your [ __ ] straight
how in the [ __ ] are we supposed to take
these people
seriously
mitch mcconnell votes to acquit donald
trump
and immediately gives a speech that he
wrote 10 days before
about how donald trump is [ __ ] guilty
and yet we're supposed to listen to
these [ __ ]
about cancer culture and unity this is
the people we're supposed to take
seriously
are you [ __ ] kidding me
well excuse me
excuse me for wanting unity against you
[ __ ]
and excuse me for wanting to cancel your
dumb [ __ ] ideas
cause they [ __ ] suck [ __ ] em